et si l'eau se fait plus rare certains
pourtant n'ont pas renoncé à planter des
arbres des arbres fruitiers pommiers
Poirier et prunier une soixantaine au
total à villedomet près de
Château-Renault objectif pour
l'association des Croqueurs de Pommes de
Touraine à l'origine du projet
sensibiliser les enfants aux variétés
régionales vous voyez ce reportage de
Faustine une
[Applaudissements]
de cette classe de villedomet écoute les
consignes ils s'apprête à planter 60
arbres fruitiers au bord de l'étang de
l'archevêque avec l'association les
Croqueurs de Pommes le but c'est avant
tout des sensibiliser à l'utilité des
fruits des arbres fruitiers et nous
notre but c'est de préserver de
conserver les variétés fruitières
anciennes de manière à ce qui est une
variété génétique qui se concerne car
ces arbres fruitiers appartiennent à des
variétés anciennes historiques de
Touraine par exemple des prunes
Sainte-Catherine des pommes Mercier ou
encore des poires bonnes de Bunny ce
sont des variétés que nous ne trouvons
plus dans le commerce
aujourd'hui Golden Gala Granny Smith
c'est
70% de la vente de pommes en France
si je vous parle de Mercier de marrange
de reinette Dumont ça parle plus
beaucoup quand même
c'est quoi c'est un peu mieux
prothèse de Paris non c'est un poirier
de cette activité pédagogique les
écoliers en ressortent les genoux
terreux et la main verte d'abord on a
creusé tu fais un trou tu le plantes tu
remets la terre et après tu mets des
copeaux bah on attend toujours
l'arrosoir pour l'arroser
c'est le département qui finance
l'opération avec pour objectif de mettre
en valeur ses décrets de verdure avec un
verger dont les fruits seront destinés
aux habitants ce sera à voir si ce sera
libre service ou si il y aura une
journée dédiée à ça avec peut-être voilà
une fête un événement dans tous les cas
il va falloir patienter avant la récolte
car ces arbres ne devraient pas donner
de fruits avant 5 ans